[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هل تشهد القاره
الافريقيه اصول العصر الفرنسي وصعود القطب
الروسي
الم تمنى فرنسا بخسائر عسكريه وسياسيه
توجد بانسحاب قواتها من مالي وجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وبوركينا فاسو وتراجع
دورها مقابل تقدم روسيا امنيا وعسكريا من
خلال مجموعه باجنر لماذا تفشل فرنسا في
افريقيا رغم تاريخها الاستعماري الطويل
لدول القاره في حين تنجح روسيا في استقطاب
قاده هذه الدول ونسجي مصالح متبادله بينهم
اما ان لفرنسا رؤيه مغيره لوضعها السابق
تعفيها من الانخراط عسكريا ودفع اثمان
يستفيد منها الخصمان الروسي والصيني هل
لروسيا مقومات حقيقيه لتشكل بديلا عن
فرنسا التي خدت المنطقه عن ظهر قلب
اسئله نطرحها على الدكتور جون مسيحه
الخبير في العلوم السياسيه والاقتصاد
والمتحدث الرسمي في التيار الوطني من
باريس وعلى الدكتور محمود الافندي الخبير
في شؤون الروسيه من موسكو
نبدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا مع السيد جون
مسيحه من باريس جون لماذا وصلت فرنسا الى
هذا المستوى الى مرحله تتجرا عليها دول
افريقيه تطردها من من اراضيها وايضا يحرج
رؤساؤها وممثلها كما حصل مؤخرا مع الرئيس
الفرنسي امام رئيس الكونغو الديمقراطيه اي
وضع اصبحت فيه فرنسا تجاه دول القاره
الافريقيه هذه الايام
مساء الخير بص حضرتك في سببين
للاسئله اللي تطرحها على السياسه الفرنسيه
وانسحابها من افريقيا السبب الاولاني ان
عندنا قيادات فرنسيه منذ حوالي اربعين سنه
لا تامن
بهاويه الفرنسيه ولا تامن بالسياده
الفرنسيه ولا تامن
بالقوه الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه خارج البلاد
فلذلك الاربعين سنه اللي فاتت
يعني نشهد انسحاب
متدرج
للقوات الفرنسيه مش بس من افريقيا من
التاثير الفرنسي العام عبر الدول العالم
ولا سيما الدول اللي كانت مستعمرها فرنسا
ده اول شيء ثاني شيء القيادات الافريقيه
ذات نفسها والقيادات البلاد اللي كانت
مستعمرها فرنسا
يستخدم ريع الذاكره
الاستعماريه
لتحاول ان تسيطر على شعوبها
وتشرح لشعوبها لماذا في تاخير في النمو
الافريقي ولماذا في فقره مستديم في القاره
الافريقيه فلما تضع السببين دول امام بعض
ننظر ان هناك باب لتدخل قوات اخرى قوات
اولا فخوره بسيادتها فخوره بهويتها فخوره
بالدور التي تلعبه على الساحه
الدوليه وعلى الساحه الافريقيه
ده شيء وتاني شيء
مثل الصين مثلا اول اول دوله بتيجي تنافس
السياده الفرنسيه او التاثير الفرنسي على
القاره الافريقيه منذ حوالي 30 سنه كانت
الصين اولا ومنذ كم عام دلوقتي روسيا ايضا
في اطار لكن الصين غرب
والشرقين ربما تنافس اقتصاديا وبشكل يعني
من دون ضجه اذا اذا صح التعبير لكن روسيا
هي التي تحل فعليا محل فرنسا لكن اسمح لي
هنا سيدي جون عندما تتحدث وكان هذا
الانسحاب الفرنسي هو انسحاب طوعي هو ليس
انسحابا طوعيا هو طرد
لفرنسا يعني المشهد الذي تبعناه بين
الرئيس ماكرون ورئيس الكونغو الديمقراطيه
يدل على هذه الحاله التي وصلت اليها فرنسا
في في افريقيا يعني المساله ليست انسحابا
طوعيا وعدم ايمان بالدور الفرنسي في
افريقيا بقدر ما ان الدول الافريقيه ضاقت
زرعا بهذا الوجود الفرنسي وتبحث عن بديل
تجده في روسيا
الكلام ده غلط لان لماذا روسيا تستطيع ان
تدخل تتدخل في افريقيا
هناك اراده لذلك هناك سياسه لذلك من هي
السياسه الفرنسيه او الاراده الفرنسيه
التي بها فرنسا تمكس في القاره الافريقيه
وتحارب النزاعات الاجنبيه مثل النزاع
الروسي او
المنافسه الروسيه لتاثير الفرنسي في
افريقيا مفيش
افريقيا بيروح يدافع عن وجود فرنسا في
افريقيا ولا بيروح يشرح للافرقه لماذا
فرنسا لازم تنسحب ولماذا فرنسا لازم يعني
ينبغي عليها ان تتراجع في تاثيرها على
الدول الافريقيه اي تاثير اجنبي من ورائه
افتخار قومي من ورائه استراتيجيه قوميه
للتاثير وهذا ما تفعله روسيا اليوم وهذا
كانت ما تفعله الصين على الاطار الاقتصادي
والاطار المالي كان لا يوجد اي استراتيجيه
تاثيريه ولا اي اراده ان فرنسا تنكز في
افريقيا وتزرع
باقي
اتركه التاريخ الاستعماري
اذا كان فرنسا ما بتدافعش عن مصالحها ما
فيش بلد تانيه هتدافع عن مصالحها بدالها
فبالتالي فرنسا بتنسحب وطبعا اي شيء اي
بلد بتنسحب من قاره بيجي بدالها بلاد
تانيه فخوره عن قومها فخورتها فخوره عن
هويتها سيد محمود عن تاثيرها سيد محمود
ماذا يذهب ماكرون الى الدول الافريقيه
ليقول لهم
ليشرح لهم سبب الانسحاب هذا الانسحاب
الطوعي الذي تقوم به
فرنسا من دول افريقيه يعني هو ذاهب فقط
لشرح هذه هذه النقطه ولياتي من يريد ان
ينافس فرنسا او يحل محل فرنسا لا مشكله
لدى باريس في ذلك ما رايك
اوقاتك سيدي الكريم والاخوه المشاهدين
للدكتور جان طبعا من باريس فعليا اذا
راينا يعني لمحه تاريخيه صغيره فعليا ما
يسمى الاستعمار الحديث اللي انشئ بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه على دول افريقيا
وقصد على 14 دوله افريقيه هناك دول كثيره
من افريقيا تحررت من الاستعمار القديم
ولكن في 14 دوله حتى الان تحت الاستعمار
الفرنسي ومنها الكونغو وبوركينا فاسو
ومالي وافريقيا الوسطى كل هذه الدول تحت
ما يسمى الاستعمار الحديث الفرنسي فعليا
انا برايي الخاص انه بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا اعطت
شراره لكل دول العالم ومنها الدول
الافريقيه لاطلاق ما يسمى ثوره الاستقلال
الحقيقي والسياده والتمتع في الموارد
الطبيعيه لهذه الاراضي الغنيه فعليا يعني
خلينا قوه واقعيين فرنسا لا تريد الخروج
يعني على سبيل المثال الاستخراج الذهب من
بوركينا فاسو والالماس امكانيات هائله هي
الشركات الفرنسيه النيجر على سبيل المثال
اعطيني سبب المثال النيجر يستخرج من
الفرنسيين اربعين بالمئه من اليورانيوم
ويذهب الى المفاعلات النوويه الفرنسيه مع
ان النيجر 90% من النيجر ليس فيها كهرباء
هذه النداء والشراره اعطت الان الدول
الافريقيه للطلب بخروج فرنسا وفرنسا
فيزيائيا لا تستطيع السيطره الان على هذه
الدول لا بعدد الجنود ولا في الجيش ولا
ايضا حتى في الاسلحه ووضع الاقتصادي السيء
نوعا ما وخصوصا على مستوى العسكري وخصوصا
بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه يعني بعد المعركه
الان نرى جيدا ان هناك يعني فعليا فرنسا
تفتقر الى الموارد او القوه للسيطره على
السيطره على فرنسا ايضا على
الافندي روسيا ايضا لا تمتلك لا تمتلك هذه
القوات ايضا روسيا ما هي الطرف الرئيسي
المنخرط بالحرف في اوكرانيا هذا اولا
ثانيا يعني هل
لماذا
نعتبر بان فرنسا هنا مجبره على الانسحاب
في حين ان الدول الافريقيه ليس لديها
بدائل يعني لا على صعيد العسكري لديها
بدائل ولا على صعيد الامني وهي تبحث عن
بدائل ربما تجدها في مجموعه فاجنر وغيرها
ولكن بالنهايه ليست هناك بدائل افريقيه
اللي تطلب من روسيا الانسحاب او لتطردها
عفوا من فرنسا
اول شيء روسيا ليست بحاجه لادخال قواتها
الى افريقيا هذا امر مهم جدا فلذلك
العمليه العسكريه خاصه لا تزداد فلوسها في
افريقيا روسيا تتعامل مع دول افريقيا كدول
ما يسمى ذات سياده وارجاع السياده الى هذه
الدول ففعليا يمكن ان تقدم روسيا نوع من
انواع الدعم الاقتصادي والدعم العسكري عن
طريق الاسلحه بالاضافه الى ما يسمى
الترابط مع هذه الدول السياسيه الدعم
السياسي امر مهم جدا فعليا لذلك اشارات
العمليه عسكريه امر مهم جدا وفعليا روسيا
دخلت افريقيا هي تاريخيا يعني روسيا لديها
سمعه ورثتها على الاتحاد السوفيتي هي
الدوله الوحيده يلي قامت بتحرير افريقيا
لنتذكر بس بالاخوه المشاهدين يعني فعليا
بروسيا بدات بشمال افريقيا فعليا ب 56 لما
اوقفت العدوان الثلاثي على مصر حررت
الجزائر بشمال افريقيا ساعدت المغرب على
التحرر بالفرنسا وبالاضافه الان الى قرار
الامم المتحده عام 1960 يلي اجمته الاتحاد
السوفيتي استقلت 17 دوله افريقيه عن
الاستعمار الانجليزي او الفرنسي اول
بلجيكا او البرتغالي ففعليا سوري روسيا
لديها سمعه قويه ولديها علاقات وطيده مع
ادوان افريقيا بالاضافه بالاضافه ان الدول
الافريقيه تعلم جيدا ان روسيا لا تسرق هذه
الدول روسيا تتعامل كدوله لما يسمى على
مستوى واحد اقتصادي يعني اهم شيء هذه
الدول فعليا تخرج لا تخرج من الاستعمار
تخرج الاستعمار يعني من السرقه هذه الدول
تسرق وتنهب وتعيش على مستوى الفقر وليس
لديها حل غير ان تبدا باستقلالها لتعيش
نفكر اخوه المشاهدين 30% من ورد
نقطه مهمه يستهزء كريم وردات طبيعيه عن
الارض هي في افريقيا جدول مندليف كله في
افريقيا هذه الدول تعيش بسبب فقر يعني هذه
النقطه هذه النقطه المهمه التي ذكرها
السيد الافندي
الدول الافريقيه تسرق تسرق الدول
الافريقيه من فرنسا هذا ما يقوله سيد
الافندي وتحاول الدول الافريقيه ان تطرد
هذا السارق الذي هو فرنسا ما ردك على ذلك
الكلام الحديث ده حديث غريب الشكل ممكن
يكون هناك روسيه من وراء هذا الحديث او
نوع من السذاجه في التحليل الموقف ما فيش
حاجه اسمه سرقه فرنسا لما بتاخد
اليورانيوم من النيجر بتدفعه بسعر السوق
ما فيش حاجه اسمها سرقه
لكل ما بتاخده فرنسا من الدول الافريقيه
بتدفع سعره بسعر السوق ما فيش حاجه ما فيش
حاجه ما فيش حاجه اسمها اسمها سرقه ده اول
شيء ثاني شيء الاستعمار الفرنسي طارق
منشات وترك مستشفيات وترك طرق وترك جامعات
وطرق تعليم وترك كثير من الادوات النمو
الحديث واخد بالك لكن
التاثير الروسي الحديث والتاثير الصيني
الاقتصادي ده يعتبر استبدال استعمار فرنسي
باستعمار اخر لكن استعمار
الصيني
الشعوب فقط الشعوب في في
كلامي نتحدث عن الدول الافريقيه يعني
الدول الافريقيه بما تعانيه اليوم ما
نشاهده اليوم نتحدث عن دول حديثه تركت لها
فرنسا ارثا حضاريا
وتطورا عمرديا وغير ذلك على شكل الذين
نراه اليوم
اكيد ما انت لما تبص هقول لها هفهمك شيء
في دول مثلا مثل اثيوبيا كان ما فيش فيها
استعمار في دوله زي ليبيريا ما كانش فيها
استعمار هل هذه الدول اللي كان ليست لها
استعمار اوروبي او استعمار فرنسي النهارده
دول غنيه لا
فما نقدرش نعتبر ان الاستعمار في ذات نفسه
حتى لو القيادات الافريقيه بتحاول تستغل
ذاكره وريع الذاكره الاستعماريه عشان تفهم
شعوبها من ان فقر ده لا يعني ان ده حقيقه
ومش معنى ان روسيا بكره هتحل محل فرنسا او
الصين تحل محل فرنسا ده لا يعني ان الدول
الافريقيه ستختني وسايبين لها سكه نمو بل
بالعكس دول زي الصين واسال الشعوب
الافريقيه اللي بتستقبل استثمارات صينيه
وتستخدم وبتستقبل كائنات جائلات استثماريه
صينيه اسال مكان هؤلاء الشعوب بيختنوا عن
وجود الصين الصين موجوده عشان تاخد فلوس
وعشان تغتني على راس الشعوب الافريقيه دون
ان تترك اي نوع من انواع التقدم في هؤلاء
البلاد فالواحد طبعا ممكن اللي قيادات
الافريقيه تشرح للشعوبها ان كل ما هم
يسئون الحياه مسؤوليه فرنسا الكلام ده
بروباجندا غالطه وكاذبه وبكره والتاريخ
وبيننا بكره للشعوب دي ستفهم اذا في فرنسا
انتحبت وحل محلها دول زي روسيا او زي
الصين بكره الايام بيننا وبكره الشعوب دي
هتندم اشد الندم على هذا الاستبدال الندم
ستندم هذه الشعور سيد الافندي
يعني تعقب على كلامه يقول كلامي انا كلامي
انا عايش في روسي انا طيب ما رايك في جورج
ميلوني رئيس وزراء ايطاليا من حوالي السنه
صرحت بشكل رسمي وبخطاب لها ان فرنسا تسرق
النيجر باليورانيوم تسرق الذهب من بوركينا
فاسو فعليا هل هذا جورج ميلونيا
قالت عندما خافت فرنسا من العلاقات لائق
جورجيا ميلوني وفي ترجع للانترنت صديقي
هذا كلام موجود فيك ترجع له الان اذا فيك
وقتك
لا جورج فرنسا
انا لم اقاطعك
دكتور
تشال لا مقاطعه
دعني اكمل لن اقاطعك اتفضل اتفضل اتفضل
اتفضل فعليا هم يسرقون يعني
هذا الكلام اذا كوباندا يعني تصور انه
فرنسا تدخلت
حتى قناه جورج دخلت قواتها ليبيا للخوفها
من علاقات الطاقه بين ليبيا وايطاليا يعني
فعليا دائما فرنسا تحاول ان تسرق كل الدول
كافيه في مجال الطاقه او في كل مجالات
بالنسبه ما تركت لهم الطرق اعطيك على سبيل
المثال فاستخرج اليورانيوم طيب عيب على
فرنسا ان تعمل مفاعلات نوويه انظر الى
روسيا الان تعمل مشروع الضبعه مفاعل نووي
في مصر 20% بالكهرباء بعد اربع سنين اكبر
مفاعل في الشرق الاوسط او في المنطقه
العربيه راح يكون في مصر لماذا لا تعمل
فرنسا وهي تسرق اليوراني من ان تعمل لهم
مفاعل نووي 90% من نيجر بلا كهرباء اليس
هذا الطرق تؤديها شويه الطرق ماذا تفعل
فرنسا اين التقدم اين الجامعات كل افريقيا
تدرس خارج فرنسا اين الجامعات في النيجر
اين الجامعات في بوركينا فاسو روسيا انشات
في سؤال عفوا
فقط فقط
سؤالي سؤالي سيد الافندي سؤالي طيب هذه
فرنسا هل روسيا بديل افضل يعني هل روسيا
قلبها على الدول الافريقيه هل ستاتي روسيا
والصين الها 30 سنه في في افريقيا
اقتصاديا وبشكل ناعم لكن لم تغتني الدول
الافريقيه ولم يتغير
يعني لم يتغير شكلها ما النموذج الجديد
الذي ستقدمه روسيا
طبعا سؤالك مهم جدا سيدي الكريم روسيا لا
تستعمر ولا عمرها ما كانت دوله امبرياليه
ولا استعماريه ففعليا روسيا تقدم ما يسمى
امتلاك لمملكات البلد لان روسيا تملك 43
بالمئه من موارد الارض وافريقيا تملك 30%
عندما تستخدم انا مع بنكد استاذي الكريم
مع بنات يعني فعليا
كانت استعماريه اعطيني دوله كانت تستعملها
روسيا اعطوني دوله واحده فقط دوله واحده
فالروسيا تقدم الاستقلال الاستقلال
الحقيقي ان يصبح لديك سياده ان تصبح لديك
سياسه تستخدم الموارد بالسعر العالمي طلعت
يعني يقول لي اين الدول فقيره وكانك تقول
ان روسيا هي دوله عفوا كانك تقول روسيا هي
دوله لتحريم شعور عفوا ولتمكين الشعوب
يعني هذا فروسيا
طبعا اعطيك مثال اعطيك مثال سيدي الكريم
اعطيك مثال هل تعلم انه 14 دوله باوروبا
انشاتها روسيا ما كانت موجوده انشاتها
روسيا وغسل الاستعمار السويدي انشات ثلاث
دول بلطيق انشات حرت بلغاريا من الاستعمار
العثماني حررت اليونان حررت رومانيا حررت
صربيا كلها غير موجوده بهذه الدول روسيا
الدول حتى المانيا المانيا الموجوده كان
في عرض كان في عرض من ان يقسم ان يلغي
المانيا ولكن ستالين وقف على كلمه
جمعيه خيريه لانشاء الدول
روسيا تريد السلام روسيا روسيا تريد
السلام
في العالم سيد الكريم السلام في العالم هو
من يعطي لروسيا قوتها لانها فعليا تصبح ان
يكون لكل دوله لها سياده ولكل دوله
تجيب السفير الروسي تتحدث معه وكان يمكن
مش هيتكلم بالطريقه اللي كانت بيتكلم فيها
الاخ من موسكو لان ده بيتكلم اكنه واحد من
السلطه من القياده الروسيه او متحدث
الرسمي عن بوتين
في العالم
من ماشي ما هو انا انا بحترم رايه بقول لك
بس ان ده ده ده اللغه البروباجنديه بتاع
الكرملين وبتاع بوتين انا ده رايي وانا
بحترمه بس بقول ان الراي ده غلط والراي ده
كاذب ليه لان ما فيش ما فيش اي حد في
العالم ممكن يصدق ان دوله ممكن تعمل حاجه
بس عشان
اذا سمحت التطرق لكلمه الكذب ما في داعي
لها
خطا خطا
مع احترامي لك سيدي الكريم
ماشي خلاص انا بسحب الكلمه وبتاسف انا
عايز اقول لك ان الكلام ده غلط والكلام ده
بروباجندا روسيه لان كما قال الجنرال كان
يقول الدول لا ليست لها اصدقاء الدول لها
مصالح
وروسيا طبعا كانت دوله امبرياليه والاتحاد
السوفيتي كم دوله ان كانت دوله امبرياليه
في كوريا وفي الفيتنام وفي افريقيا كانت
دوله امبرياليه مثلها مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ده ما فيش اي
حد بيختلف عليه اما فكره ان روسيا بتفعل
في افريقيا لان افريقيا
دون ان تسعى دون ان تسعى عن اي مصالح ودون
ان تسعى عن اي اهداف قوميه لها ده كلام
يعني سوري يعني كلام ساذج او كلام
بروباندا طبعا روسيا لها مصالح زي مثل ما
فرنسا لها مصالح مثل ما امريكا لها مصالح
روسيا لها مصالح روسيا تود ان تحل محل
فرنسا وتخلق لنفسها ساحه تاثيريه في
القاره الافريقيه
هي موجوده في افريقيا لكي تستغل اذا اذا
كانت فرنسا تفشل اذا كانت فرنسا تفشل اذا
كانت فرنسا تتراجع اذا كانت فرنسا تطرد من
الدول الافريقيه
وروسيا تجد نفسها مرحبا بها من قبل هذه
الدول اين المشكله حتى بمنطق المصالح الذي
تتحدث عنه الا يحق لروسيا ان تحتل محل
فرنسا في هذه الدول وخصوصا انه رئيس
بوركينا فاسو مثلا عفوا رئيس وزراء
بوركينا فاسو يقول روسيا هي خيار المنطق
في هذه الديناميه
بوركينا فاسو التي طردت القوات الفرنسيه
الكلام ده
الكلام ده غلط لان طبعا الشعوب الافريقيه
زرع في مخها منذ سنين ان كل ما هي تعيشه
من فقره ودين يرجع للاستعمار الفرنسي
فهناك يعني كراهيه مبنيه على كذب بالنسبه
للدور اللي بتلعبه فرنسا في عدم نمو
افريقيا انت عارف ان في سنه 42 لما كان
الجيش الالماني بتاع روميل عند العلمين في
مصر كان الشعب المصري بيشجع القوات
النازيه مش عشان كان حبا للقوات النازيه
بل عشان كان بيكافح التاثير الانجليزي على
مصر في ذات الوقت هناك نفس الشيء بيحصل في
افريقيا لما تزرع في قلوب وفي افكار
الشعوب ان هناك مسؤول عن الفقر ومسؤول عن
الدين ومسؤول عن عدم نمو اسمه فرنسا
طبعا اي دوله بتيجي بيرحب بها لان طبعا
عايزين يطردوا ما هو يعتبروك عدو تاريخي
للنمو وليه الغنى بتاع البلاد مش ده لا
يعني ان بعد سنه اذا اذا فرنسا انسحب
التماما من هذه البلاد ده لا يعني ان بكره
روسيا مش هتكره بنفس الطريقه مثل ما
القوات الالمانيه الكوره هات فيما بعدها
طيب سيدنا افندي
ما هي المقومات التي تملكها روسيا للحلول
محل فرنسا فرنسا ذات تاريخ الاستعمار
الطويل الاقرب الى هذه الدول وشعوبها
وثقافاتها يعني فرنسا زرعت ما تعتبره خيرا
ما تعتبروه شرا لكن في النهايه
لفرنسا جذور في هذه الدول
يعني ما الذي ستقدمه في المقابل روسيا
كوافد جديد اليها
اي كلمه اي كلمه تخرج خارج نطاق الدعايه
الاوروبيه والاعلام الاوروبي هو بروباندا
يعني لديك راي مخالف فانت من اين يكون هذا
العالم يقول الدول الدول الفرنسي تقدم
الخير يعني لماذا الاستعمار طب شو عم
بتساوي فرنسا بافريقيا اذا بتقدم لك خير
فتطلع خلاص يعني تعيفوني يموتوا يعني ليش
عم تقدمونه خير يعني
انتم جمعيه خيريه وليست روسيا يعني فعليا
هو يبرر كلمه الاستعمار الاستعمار طوله
عمره معروف انه هو الدول للسرق بوارد
طبيعيه لدوله اخرى يفتح جدول مندليف وشور
مورد طبيعيه اللي حتى الان تسرق وحتى على
الدول المتحرك على الطريق الشركات
الاجنبيه الموجوده وعن طريق صندوق النقد
الدولي وعن طريق صندوق النقد الدولي الذي
فعليا هو اداب يبعد الامريكيه والغرب
لاستبداد هذه الدول عن طريق النسبه
المئويه العاليه ويدخلوا الدول في ديون
ففعليا ماذا تقدم
عندما تدخل او تحرر او ما يسمى تحرر اي
منطقه تعطي يمكن ان تعطي البنيه التحتيه
لماذا ليس هناك في افريقيا
اسالي سيد كريم ليس هناك مفاعلات دولي
لانتاج الكهرباء ليس هناك مصانع ليس هناك
يعني تملك افريقيا كل شيء للصناعه وليست
لديها صناعه لماذا مع انه يد العامله جدا
رخيصه وموجوده وعدد سكان هائل ما هي الصين
الصين عباره ليست لديها موارد ولكن لديها
يد عامله انظر اين الصين لانها مستقله
بينما افريقيا غير مستقله عندما تدخل
روسيا او يخلع الاستعمار الفرنسي من هذه
المنطقه تصبح تصبح هذه الدول تستطيع
استقطاب الاستثمارات العالميه ان تبدا في
الصناعه ان تبدا في الانتاج روسيا ستقدم
نموذج مختصين عفوا
روسيا روسيا ستقدم نموذج مختلف عن الصين
يعني الصين نموذجها يشبه النموذج الفرنسي
طبعا
لا لا روسيا تستطيع نرد الاستقلال
الاستقلال وتقوي الاستقلال وتقوي السياده
وتقوي السياده وتساعد الدوله على السياده
العسكريه والسياده الاقتصاديه والسياده
الاجتماعيه تستطيع الدوله ان تنتج حتى
الان هذه الدولة قاطعه تحت الاستعمار يعني
حلم كل افريقيا موجود في افريقيا ان يواجه
الى فرنسا هذا امر جيد يعني
الافضل
قالت الافضل ان تعطوا اوروبا انواع تعطوا
افريقيا اموالهم ويستطيعون ان يعملوا
بنفسهم اعطهم يعني ساعدهم بانشاء ما يسمى
ومعامل تقليديه لكن فرنسا كانت فرنسا
بقواتها عفوا فرنسا بقواتها كانت على
الاقل يعني
تحد من عدم الاستقرار الذي
تشتهر به هذه المنطقه يعني الامن بحده
الادنى كانت تؤمن فرنسا خروج فرنسا سيترك
هذه الدول
مشرعه امنيا وبالتالي حتى الصين
باستثماراتها كانت تستفيد بشكل او باخر من
الحاله الامنيه الموجوده التي كانت تؤمنها
فرنسا روسيا هل لديها هذا البديل
طبعا هناك في شركات امنيه روسيه قويه
استقرار ما يسمى يمكن اعطائه كل ليس فاقده
في النص ليش شركات عسكريه روسيه كثيره غير
يعني يمكن تاسيسها فعليا يمكن اعطاء ما
يسمى السياده الامنيه يمكن اعطاء النصائح
اعطاء المؤسسات الامنيه هذا امر مهم جدا
شوف الفوضى تاتي دائما عندما يخرج الشخص
بلا عمل عندما يكون لديه عمل وياكل قوته
من يده لا يخرج الى الشارع ولا يعمل فوضى
ففعليا او فرنسا ماذا تعمل توصل الدوله
الى حد الفقر وتسرقها وتخرج من ذلك الشعب
بلا اكل بجوع ستخرج ويبدا الفوضى في كل
مكان فعليا روسيا البديل عن تقويه تقويتها
وتدريب القوى الامنيه في الدرب لدي السلاح
لدي القوه الخبره في
الحروب طبعا ستقدم هذا يمكن تقدم هذا
لافريقيا يمكن ان مؤمن ان تؤمن لها مصانع
ان تؤمن لها كل شيء لي الاستفاده لانه
فعليا الفوضى الفوضى بنسميها فوضى الخلاقه
اوروبا دائما يعني على سبيل المثال اي
دوله عربيه اذن الربيع العربي كان عندما
يخرج اي دوله عربيه او اي حكومه عربيه
مكانها الفوضى لماذا لماذا لانه حتى الان
الدول العربيه هي
دولارات حتى الان
عفوا السيده افندي لكن سيد جون اكيد تابعت
اخر اخر فيديو لرئيس الكونغو الديمقراطيه
وهو يقول يوجه ويمض اصابعه ويقول للرئيس
الفرنسي عاملون باحترام هذه الطريقه التي
تتعاملون بها معنا يجب ان تتغير
طبعا تابعت هذا هذا الموضوع ربما هذا يلخص
يلخص هذه النقمه الافريقيه اتجاه فرنسا ما
رايك
رايي ان هو ان هذا الرئيس يتبع لكل
القيادات الافريقيه الذي شرحت للشعوبها ان
اسباب الفقر وعدم النموها والاستعمار
فبالتالي هذا الرساله ليست لمنويل الرساله
اللي ارسلها رئيس الكونغو وارسلها لشعبه
عشان يوري عشان يوري لشعبه ان ان هو يعني
نوع من اللي بيعمل ثوره على المستعمر
القديم الفرنسي وطبعا الكلام ده كله غلط
والكلام ده كله كدب بالنسبه لرئيس الكونغو
والسياساته واود ان اقول ان الاستعمار
كلمه استعمار دي كلمه سحريه
يستخدموها كل القيادات الافريقيه منذ 50
سنه عشان يشرحوا لشعبهم لماذا ليس في نمو
اريد ان اذكر ان في القاره الاسيويه في
بلاد كثيره استعمرت كوريا تايوان حتى
الصين كانت مستعمره من تايوان اشمعنى
هؤلاء البلاد اللي كان فيها كمان
الاستعمار يعني اكتر
واكتر عنف
في افريقيا كل الدول دي
كل كل الدول دي اختنت وعملت ناضجه وعملت
نمو واصبح دلوقتي شعوبها
بيتميزوا بدرجه نمو مثلك
عفوا
عندك دوله عفوا عندك عندك دوله
لو سمحت ممكن اخلص انا سبتك تتكلم سنه ربع
ساعه سنه سنه
دوله دوله هايتي اللي كانت بتفتخر ان هي
اول دوله سوداء مستقله هل الدوله دي دوله
فيها نموه وفيها غنى تعتبر بكره فقر وبكر
ببقعه جوع حتى لو كانت هناك اول دوله
العربيه المصريه انت تعدد الدول ولا تقول
لنا ما السبب ما السبب يعني لماذا تلك
الدول تايوان
وكوريا والصين التي كانت مستعمره الوضع
اختلف فيها بعد الاستعمار والدول
الافريقيه الوضع فيها بقيه كما حليه من هو
المسؤول
لان لان عدم عدم نمو البلد بيرجع للبلد
نفسها بيرجع للقياده البلد وبيرجع للشعوب
البلد الواحد مش لازم يحمل مسؤوليه فقره
ومسؤوليه فشله لاشياء تاريخيه او لاشياء
خارجيه الواحد لازم ينظر في الاول للاسباب
الداخليه للفقر وعدم النمو قبل ما يضع
كلام سحري
بيحاولوا يشرحوا به عدم النمو لمده اربعين
سنه عندك كوريا كوريا الجنوبيه كان
الانتاج بتاعها مثل زيمبابوي في سنه دوله
زيمباب وفي سنه 1965 اصبح النهارده
الانتاج القومي بتاع كوريا الشباب كوريا
الغربيه مثل انتاج البرتغال في اوروبا
لماذا لان دي شعوب بتشتغل وشعوب قيادتها
باقيه على سؤالي يبقى في في اطار عفوا
بتسرق اول اسمع عفوا اول عفوا بس اخر كلمه
اول سارق للدول الافريقيه هي القيادات
الافريقيه القيادات الافريقيه تسرق وتنهى
شعوبها منذ اربعين سنه وتحمل هذه السرقه
لفرنسا طيب سيد جون سابقى معك في في هذه
النقطه لانه واضح نحن موضوعنا له علاقه
بفرنسا وروسيا وهذا التنافس الان فرنسا
تخرج بشكل او باخر من كلام الرئيس الفرنسي
لا يبدو ان ان هذا الخروج طوعي يعني يبدو
ان فرنسا مجبره بشكل او باخر على هذا
الخروج لكن هل ستقبل ان تحل روسيا محلها
بغض النظر كيف سيكون انعكاس وجود روسيا في
افريقيا على شعوبها لكن من باب المصالح
والمنافسه كيف ستواجه فرنسا هذا التحدي ان
تحل رو سيا محلها في دول افريقيا
انا لا اعتقد ان روسيا ممكن تحل تماما محل
فرنسا لماذا لان الوجود الاجنبي في
افريقيا ليس بس وجود عسكري او حتى بس وجود
مالي او اقتصادي في وجود ثقافي عندك
الفرانكفورنيا النهارده الناس اللي بتتكلم
فرنسي عادتها اكبر في القاره الافريقيه عن
في فرنسا نفسها وهناك في بصمه تاريخيه
وثقافيه ولغويه لفرنسا في افريقيا ودي مش
روسيا ولا الصين اللي هيقدروا يحلوا محلها
من يوم لاخر
فهناك العلاقات العسكريه او التاثير
العسكري او التاثير الاقتصادي موجود
النهارده ممكن بكره فرنسا ترجع بنفس
التاثير لكن الجذور الثقافيه والجذور
اللغويه التي تركتها فرنسا عميقه ما فيش
ثقافه روسيه بكره هتحل محل الثقافه
الفرنسيه في الدول الافريقيه ولا ثقافه
صينيه هتحل محل الثقافه الفرنسيه اما
بالنسبه للتاثيرات الجديده سواء انها
عسكريه او انها ماليه دي تاثيرات وقتيه
النهارده روسيا موجوده بكره ممكن قياده
فرنسيه اخرى واستراتيجيه فرنسيه اخرى ترجع
الى تاثير في افريقيا وممكن تعتمد في ذات
الوقت على الجذور الثقافيه واللغويه الذي
التي موجوده في افريقيا والذي ما فيش اي
دوله ممكن تنزعها ابدا طيب سيد الافندي
يعني نحن نتحدث عن افريقيا لكن ليست حتى
الان يعني ليست كل دول افريقيا
تخرج من العباءه الفرنسيه
وتفتح زراعيها
الضيف الروسي
هناك يعني اصبحت المنطقه هجينه بعض الدول
كذلك وبعض الاخر ما زال حتى الان تحت
العباءه الفرنسيه هذا الامر في ظل تنافس
روسي فرنسي الا يمكن ان ينعكس ايضا على
دول القاره الافريقيه وبالتالي يكون هناك
نوع من ليس التنافس انما التناقض وربما
زعزعه الاستقرار بين هذه الدول الاعتبار
ان كل من هذه الدول سيكون ميوله مختلف عن
الاخر او ربما معادي او منافس للاخر
سؤالك جيد الكلام بس بدي اجاوب بس اعقب
على سؤالك السابق اللي سالته الدكتور جان
يعني تقول لماذا الصين والتايوان ودول
اخرى استطاعت ان تخرج من الاستعمار وانك
خرجت من الاستعمار واستقلت بينما دول
افريقيا لم تخرج من الاستعمار هي تحت
الاستعمار الحديث اعطيك
سبب واحد فقط هل يعلم هل تعلم سيدي الكريم
ان فرنسا تطبع النقود ل 14 دوله افريقيه
14 دوله افريقيه تطبع النقود حتى الان
فكيف هذا ليس استعمارا فهي تتحدث في مستوى
العمله وكل شيء وفي العمليه البنكيه وفي
سرقه الموارد الطبيعيه
لكن هذا برضى القيادات يا سيد افندي يا
سيدي غصبا عنهم
الافريقيه لا لا غصبا غصبا بوجود قوات
غصبا لانه لانه مسيطرين على كل الموارد
الاقتصاديه شركات وهو علي يجيب اخراجه
اخراج القوات
الدوله
انت مصري
لما عمم جمال عبد الناصر قناه السويس
مباشره من ادوات الثلاثي منين اتى من
فرنسا وبريطانيا واسرائيل فرنسا وبريطانيا
لماذا لان فعليا قرار سيادي بالتامين يجب
تامين كل الشركات الفرنسيه الموجوده
الموجوده في افريقيا عندها سيصبح ملك
البوارد الطبيعيه ربك رب العالمين خلقها
لهذا للشعب الموجود هناك ولي الشعب اخر
ليسرقه فالموارد الطبيعيه ملكا للارض
للشعب الموجود في هذا الارض فعليا يعني
اذكر بالعدوان الثلاثي على مصر امر مهم
جدا اعود الى سؤالك سيدي الكريم ليس هناك
تنافس روسي روسيا الاستقلال
يظهر العالم يصل
لا لا ليس هذا كلام خاطئ سيدي الكريم كلام
خاطئ ليس اسلحه فاسده كله كلام خاطئ الله
يخليك
كما هو واضح بلى هناك تنافس وهناك تقسيم
اذا صح التعبير لدول افريقيه ما بين
فرنسيه واخرى تتجه روسيه صينيه
صديقي الكريم هي الهدف العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا هدف غير مباشر لاستقلال كل
الدول هذه الشراره قلت اول حلقه هذا امر
مهم جدا العالم الان ينظر الى مركز القوه
ومركز القرار فعليا فعندما روسيا تميد جد
العالم وتقوم بعمليه لسياده العالم كله
وليستقلال كل الدول المستعمره هذه الدول
سترى في روسيا وتطلب المساعده نوعا ما هذا
امر مهم جدا واذكر امر مهم جدا هناك في
صيف القادم في بدايه الشهر السادس مؤتمر
كبير لكل كل الزعماء الافريقيين سيكون في
روسيا يعني التعاون الاقتصادي
الدول حتى الان مستعمره فهي بحاجه الى
تاسيس بنيه تحتيه اقتصاديه قويه تستطيع ان
تستخرج يعني حتى الان لا تستطيع النيجر ان
تستخرج
فعليا
تمام لا تستطيع عفوا لم تجبني على السؤال
كيف ليس هناك تنافس
فرنسا دوله مستعمره وروسيا دوله محرره هذا
امر مهم جدا روسيا ليست امبرياليه وفرنسا
امبرياليه ارجع للكلام الضيفه الكريم
الدكتور جان ما ذكرني ولا حتى الان اي بلد
يقول روسيا امبرياليه اي دوله احتلالتها
في روسيا اي دوله في العالم حتى الان اذا
تريد ان تنظر الى الاحتلال وهذا سرقه
الاثار فعليا روسيا كل متاحفها ليس هناك
اثار خارجيه انظر الى فرنسا
عفوا
دوله محرمه
دوله دوله مستعمره سيد جو ما ردك على على
هذا التوصيف مستعمره طبعا
مشاهدين مشاهدين الكرماء لقناه الجزيره
بيكتشفوا الان ان هناك دوله بتحل محل بابا
نويل اسمها روسيا اذا سمعنا تحليل
الدكتوره افندي
بروسيا بابا نويل
تصنع للخير دون ان تريد دون ان تريد دون
ان تريد اي مصلحه لنفسيه مصلحه
لاي مصلحه يقول ذلك
الكلام ده طبعا مفيش حد التاريخ
اتفضل سيد جون
دروس روسيا
ممكن ممكن اي دوله
يا دوله من فضلك
هذا الكلام غير منطقي
روسيا دوله امبرياليه واثناء الحرب واثناء
الحرب البارده روسيا اثرت في السياسه
الصينيه والسياسه الكوريه والسياسه
الكوبيه والسياسه الاريتريه وروسيا كانت
محتله مصر كان في عشرين الف مستشار عسكري
روسي في مصر اثناء مكان عبد الناصر في
سلطه مصر ورئيس مصر واريد ان اعرفك ان ان
مصر
اول بلد عربيه تخلت من الاستعمار في سنه
1922 ومصر النهارده اكتر بلد فيها عدم نمو
غير البلاد المغربيه مثل تونس ومثل المغرب
دول بلاد فاقوا مصر في رغم انهم استعمروا
لمده اطول فما لا لا تقول ان الاستعمار هو
اللي مسؤول عن كل شيء في استعمار كان في
افريقيا هذا الكلام اخر اسيا
لكن في حاجه يعني
في شيء اسمه
لا انت اللي بتقول انت بتقول انت انت
بتقول
لحد النهارده انت اللي بتقول
كلامك
عنصري اسمعني هل هناك هل هناك انت اللي
عنصر اللي انت انت تقول ان فرنسا محتله او
مستعمره حتى الان
قادرين على التحرك لانه الوقت الوقت ماذا
كانت تفعل روسيا في افغانستان الاتحاد
السوفيتي ماذا كان يفعل في افغانستان يعني
حتى يعني عفوا
يعني
حتى الان الجامعات الامور تصوير الامور
على انها ايضا جمعيات خيريه لانشاء الدول
وتحرر الدول ايضا يعني لن يقبله
اي مشاهد ولا اي عقل ولا اي منطق يعني اصل
التعامل بين الدول هو المصالح وهذا هو
المعروف يعني
حدث العاقل بهذا الامر سيد نعم
سؤال الي ولا سؤال لالك باختصار
يعني المساله مساله مصالح يا سيدي مساله
مساله
بكل العالم المسائل التعاطي الدول مع
بعضها هو على اساس مصالح كم تاخذ وكم تعطي
صحيح المصالح تكون عند المصالح تكون على
اساس طبعا المصالح ولكن عندما تقول دوله
التعامل مع روسي دوله ذات سياده وليست
دوله مستعمره هذا امر مهم جدا ما فعلت
الاتحاد
ما تفعله امريكا الاتحاد السوفيتي
افغانستان بنى جامعات ومدارس
على هذه المدارس والجامعات ماذا فعل
امريكيه في افغانستان 20 سنه الدمار فقط
على حدود الاتحاد السوفياتي بينما فرزت
بين افريقيا ليس على حدودكم
باختصار فرنسا لم تترك اي شيء باختصار
شديد لم لم تترك اي ارث لهذه الدول
باختصار شديد سيد جون
لا طبعا لحد يومنا هذا البلاد الافريقيه
والبلاد العربيه عايشه على نتائج
الاستعمار في كل المجالات ومن ساعه ما
الاستعمار في هذه البلاد بتبطل هذه البلاد
تدهورت وده الواقع شكرا يرجع شكرا
الافريقيه انها تتساءل على المسؤوليتها
شكرا جزيلا لك
كنت معنا من باريس وشكرا لمحمود الافندي
كان معنا من موسكو
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على المتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]